موظف قطاع مطاعم الوجبات السريعه في مرمى
الذكاء الاصطناعي والمهله امامهم ما بين
الخمس والعشر سنوات بعدها قد ينتهي الوجود
البشري في هذا المجال وتحل محله روبوتات
وانظمه اتمته كامله بدءا من اخذ الطلبات
مرورا باعداد الطعام وانتهاء بتقديمه تطور
يوصف بالثوري فللمره الاولى سينتقل الذكاء
الاصطناعي ليشغل وظائف يتعامل فيها بشكل
مباشر مع البشر مؤسس شركه فالينت المتخصصه
في الذكاء الاصطناعي روبكار قال اننا سنرى
الذكاء الاصطناعي يقفز من المكاتب الخلفيه
الى الوظائف في الواجهات الاماميه والتي
كانت حكرا على البشر كاربنتر ضرب مثلا
بتقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي المعروفه باسم
هولي والتي اثبتت قدرات على عمليه البيع
تفوق قدرات البشر كما اعتبر كاربنتر ان
محركه لا يمتلك القدره في التفوق على
البشر في حال استلامه اكثر من مليون طلب
التحذيرات من ان يحل الذكاء الاصطناعي محل
البشر ليست الاولى اذ نشرت مؤسسه جولدمان
ساكس في مارس الماضي تقريرا يوضح ان
الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان يستحوذ على نحو
300 مليون وظيفه من البشر وبدوام كامل وهو
ما قد يجعل البشر امام مستقبل غامض مع
منافسهما الذكي ولو اصطناعيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج وال
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات